ciao a tutti allora partendo dal fatto
che bla bla bla poverine noi uomini
siamo sempre stati favoriti in tutto e
per tutto già ce lo sappiamo come
chiamano anche lui però che per le donne
non è mai stato tanto facile s donne dai
cioè ma io dico riuscita a capire a cosa
sono sottoposte queste nuove rette sin
da quando sono piccole inizia un bel
giorno hanno 13 anni circa e di colpo
dite la verità l'ho creato un po di
pathos scenico e non vedete l'ora di
sapere cosa succede dopo è normale ci
abbiamo tutti noi donne perchè non me
l'hai detto tu con doni dirà quando
venire a mare non quando saranno nè cup
si della battuta e nessuno se via p vi
rendete conto dello shock primigenio di
tale evento vuole dire io personalmente
impazzire evita di dover ciclare per
sette giorni ogni mese per anni e anni e
finire solamente quando sarò un bidone
per la raccolta differenziata
roba che io alla loro età cioè pensavo a
polvere il mio picasso e poi ci stanno
le pubblicità degli assorbenti cioè roba
che noi dobbiamo preoccuparci la mattina
se usare la schiuma da barba
ora del c direttamente con il coltello
per il pane ma no non devono
preoccuparsi se prendere quello
assorbente amica assorbente quello
sottile che non si nota quello per il
ciclo abbondando per il ciclo ha sputo
quello po largo rosa che sa di cocco e
ti viene sparato con il pratico
applicatore da una matta in piena pista
da ballo
o ancora meglio quello che se prima zona
ea tira fuori i propulsori ti porta a
casa in fretta e furia
ma perché abbia capito che ormai
riportarli in classe e poi cecchino se
una non ce l'ha ma dall'altra e con fare
mica sospettoso la pelle l'indice a
bassissima voce modi ursula reggina
bisci nemica giurata di atlantyca la
cena you know how to ignaro ti avvicini
e ti guardano come se ti fosse
avvicinato con il membro di fuori un
tatuaggio di tombe in pieno petto ma
dico e poi cercheremo perché hanno
sempre mal di testa ma dico anch'io
avrei mal di testa 24 ore su 24
se dovessi dire un clima di terrore
simile ma non riesco proprio a smettere
con questi video idioti